yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a bit different and in fact this
is the type of video that I have never
done on my channel at all so it's good
to do something new every now and then
and this is going to be an unboxing
video I have a box here like this in my
mail
and I'm going to show you what it is it
is in fact I think a nice Christmas gift
that you can give to someone you want to
treat something or you can buy it for
yourself it's a nice little gift for
Christmas or other occasions of course
Christmases just around the corner so it
makes sense to do this video right
before Christmas so what is this
actually I'm going to UM do this
unboxing now as you see it's nothing
ticularly large and this in fact is
another package oh nice what is that
it's not the newest I know Apple product
or something is in fact a card game
right the chess legends card game this
is a nice one yeah a friend of mine
grandmaster yatsurugi Sookie you maybe
know him from his work online he has
done lots of commentary videos and he
worked for chess 24 for quite a while he
has done this little project doing those
cards yeah this is a card game which
features chess players so and let's have
a look sure yeah this is actually fun I
should do more of this
send me some presents that I can unbox
so we have a card game here and we have
chess players on the card so let's have
a look so
there are a couple of there also the
rules in there
okay and we also have some categories
for the players so every player here has
eight values this interesting what
values do they have the historical
rating interesting then now the number
of month as a number one for historical
rating okay so they check how long a
player was the number one spot then the
age to reach this number one spot
interesting so how its Staunton this is
the first first person here on this
supposed to be seventy six month they're
number one player this is quite a long
time at age 33 we learn and then we have
aggressiveness of playing star and
interesting
then school the quickest to win in a
classical game nine moves okay and the
longest game 94 interesting so lots of
information to proceed to to look at and
nicely done there they all have nice
little portrays this is Paul Murphy
and we got Steinitz here nice
aggressive level of Steinitz is three
three stars more figures five okay what
about the modern players Oh Magnus only
gets choose two stars in the in the
aggressiveness category and of course
this is a tricky one because all the
yeah he's still an active player
obviously
the parlor gets four stars
aggressiveness and makes sense Romney
gets three and Kasparov gets five yeah
deservedly so
that's scary yeah so it's a really nice
gift right you can give that to yourself
or for a friend or you can also just use
the set of cards maybe to play at your
chess club it's a good thing to do if
you're yeah just want to have a break
from playing of course in there nice so
it's really nice selection of players
and think probably you won't miss any
because our last guy he is smoking a
cigar
nice one see that here probably so this
is nice and in fact I think you can get
this set of cards with a discount with a
discount code that I'm going to put in
the description earlier sent that to me
so we can also have a look how to get
these I think it's easiest to get them
from Amazon yeah I I just have it yeah
the German Amazon shop and the you came
on but it's also possible to buy them
from other shops European shops and the
links are in the description so if
you're interested in this nice little
card game and I will definitely take
this with me to our chess club Christmas
party probably good fun to play
you'll always argue about stuff here I
think it's interesting how on earth can
be
maybe it was suka taught number one for
56 month that's a lot yeah I always find
the historical little ratings a little
bit strange
and again offski here's to 776 I think
this guy was barely FM strength if
anything probably less than that huh
very interesting Laska was very strong
yeah okay you you always get into
interesting discussions there if you
have a have something like that so if
you like that as a gift go to the Amazon
stores and order it you can I think even
audit with yeah quick shipment so if I
me and the German store it says it can
be delivered yeah in two days so you can
easily get it before Christmas check the
links in the description this is
important because I think you will also
get a better price then when you just
compared to just going on to an to
Amazon and ordered like that so make
sure to check the links that I'm giving
you you hope you enjoyed this video
something something different and I'll
be back with something yeah about about
about actual games soon live games or
solving some puzzles that's what I want
to do okay thanks for watching guys